いますね
ビッでミスってるんでるでる寸で偶然るっ
ウェイ
麻生あサーん明日サッカーよ楽しいカメラをいただきましたわー
ん
作ったじゃん
war
p ああああ
iaea ねええええ
うっわー悪いけど久しぶりとカメラだからもう
max 程度のございますダム5球もね以上経ちばそう youtube みたいな
感じになってますけど
やっぱね増えてほしいんですよ youtube してる人
この動画を機会にねまぁユーチューバーになってみたいなみたいな人はね
こうぜひこの動画を参考にしてください
マネーコマンチユーチューバー謎が何が普通だと思う
ぞーまずはカメラが必要ですカメラっていうか動画をするものがね
まあ最低限必要になるわけなんですよねこのアイビーっていうのはちょっとあのちゃん
の紹介し用品何がだめな砕けないから
ua ivis mini いっ
と語っていた
声ねっ
これだめだねぇ
防水だねグループ k って書いてありますねーこのアイビリっていうのは僕もね
そんな高
カメラに詳しいわけじゃないんですけどまあ自撮り専用のカメラらしいです
いわゆるこういうツールとかねこーじどりオス1圃場の hd ビデオカメラって書い
てあります
ibc ミニーはねほんと高鍋さんとかね瀬戸さん
と金持ってるんですけど
5ガンマカメラに興味ないからな
一丁の伊藤ん
あんまり声まっ適当ですね本体があればいいんですよ
わー
このでございます youtube は自分を
まあ何を続けておりますけど釣りする人がほとんどなんでね
これこ
大球場カードを用意するわー
まあ
こうなってって公園で釣りするし
いややってるああえっ
午前入っちゃっ
に貼ってにコインでプレゼント品って書いてる
2個あった bar web マダム
うーん大これでいいのかメインじゃあんまり使わないけどどっち家とかサブチャンネル
だねセカンドチャンネルの方法で行
気軽に撮っちゃいますレイズ youtube ボクサーの偉い人じゃないけど
プロユーチューバーとはそんなわけじゃないという宇宙桜いつも2年以上技術をやっ
てるんでへぇ建造言わせているんですけれども
まず最初に買うカメラはねあんまりガス2とか気にしなくて良いと思いますただこの愛
鼻責め兄の特徴はすごい画角が広いんですよ
ちょっと今からにしますいやーなんかねさしぶりにやっぱカメラを買うとテンション
上がるわけですよ
グッズのアレなんですよその例えばさが欠けが狭いってどういうことかって言ったら
こういうことです
広範囲が狭まる的な
ヒューはこれが欠けがや晴れ
めっちゃ映る打つとコツは彼らに変えまーす600だけ
あったり今こっちのカメラに変えます321
をタップナチュラル
じゃあ今はこっちのため何か得ますさあ
2ですね
はい
はいこんな感じになります白いでしょう
これがおいらの部屋でございます
このカメラもここに見てるんですけどここから俺の部屋が全部写ってます
やばい価格がねなんかユーチューバーあぁそうしたんだけど誰でもいいんですけど
仲間だっていてくれるぞ
こちらとしても嬉しいんでカメラ位置ないと
編集別にや編集後からでもいい呼ぶツールに動画たしてみたいなと思った人だしてみ
たらいいと思います名にし負は中にせよ youtube でカメラがあれば
動画がするんで
気楽に出してみたらいかがでしょうかサブチャンネルでどんどんまで使っていこうと
思ってパターン
宜しくお願いします
じゃあ